welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Tina Liu professor of Chinese
literature at Yale professor Liu's
research interests include Chinese
fiction and drama during the period
between 1550 and 1750 today we'll talk
with her about her book accidental
incest filial cannibalism and other
peculiar encounters in late Imperial
Chinese literature welcome professor Liu
thank you for having me please tell me
about the premise of your book well I
started by reading through a lot of
texts in basically encountering a lot of
ways in which writers of the period
treated the idea of human community what
ties one individual to any other mm-hmm
okay and the title of your book is
fascinating how did you come to write
the book was there any particular
inspiration um you know the the period
of literature that I work on is full of
episodes that to a modern American seem
gross and so one of the things that the
book does is tries to situate these
gross moments so I you know I ended up
writing a book all about children
feeding their parents little bits of
their bodies and people running into
relatives when they go to brothels and
only afterwards that I come up with this
title which was something that a friend
and I cooked up at a coffee house okay
share some of the stories from your book
can you give us a couple of highlights
of perhaps the cannibalism or the incest
or something else that you found
particularly interesting well one of the
amazing things is that you know this
idea of filial love the love that we
have for our parents is something that
in lady Imperial China the the Naples
ultra of it was in fact
a kind of cannibalistic act there there
there parallels in medieval Europe where
there are records of women breastfeeding
their parents for example but in in the
Chinese case it's very very literal it's
called Google and basically you shave
off a bit of your arm or your leg and
prepare it in a stew for your parents
and why would you do that well the kind
of traditional medical response would be
that it was curative but one thing I try
to do in looking at a bunch of different
examples of this is to think about the
symbolic force of it which is
essentially and I think you see it
played out in a lot of different short
stories to where the the purpose is to
almost undo the usual generative force
of humanity which is that we give birth
to children and they give birth to
children and it's a kind of ever more
dilute relationship between us and our
descendants and this kind of cannibalism
almost tries to undo that spiraling
outwards and turns the relationship
between parent and child into something
that really can't go any further because
the parent is eating up the entire child
and in one story that I treat that's
literally what happens this
daughter-in-law sells herself at a
marketplace and instead of giving birth
to a much long four grandchild she is
consumed and the money that comes out of
selling her for meat saves the husband
but essentially the choice is made
between one kind of philly allottee and
the usual way in which families change
over time which is that they give rise
to new human beings all right that's a
fascinating story that a woman was so
sold for food for food yes I mean the
thing is it
in a lot of ways a lot of the stories
that I treat in the book are about
extreme situations you know kind of
famines that are so extreme that people
have to choose between living or eating
someone or selling themselves for meat
or dynastic crises in which people lose
track of their entire families I mean
you know I think I'm not even sure that
this kind of extreme circumstance really
ever took place or took place to any
great degree it's really a way to
meditate on what would happen if you
know I think it serves the same function
of science fiction in our culture where
it's not really as if we think that a
lot of these things can take place it's
more that we need to ask questions about
human identity about human relationships
and the way to do it is to find this
hypothetical which is a kind of extreme
circumstance okay that's interesting to
me so are you let's talk a little bit
about your methodology then so are you
saying that these stories that you've
you found somewhere are they true are
they not true or you don't know they're
fictional fiction okay
I work on fix you know some of them some
records of Google for example of the
filial cannibalism are real and they you
know I have every reason to believe that
they're they're factual there are
records of there are some interesting
literary type records of extreme Google
that again I have every reason to
believe are real but the things that I'm
most interested in are when that kind of
real experience is really refracted by
imagination okay so in let's talk about
again how you did the research how you
gathered up all of the stories did you
need to travel did you find things here
at Yale for instance what did you do
well I knew it Yale and most
this book was written before I came to
here also I have a lot of small children
so my research tends to be I sit around
and read books from the library that's
my fun actually okay so in terms of you
know that the time period that you're
interested in 1558 is 1750 what about
that time period intrigues you well I
mean I feel I mean I'm just an early
modern kind of person I love the way
that there's a kind of a gap between
popular culture and elite culture I but
that it's really interesting that there
are people who are active in both I
really love going to plays in my real
life and I love the fact that the
theater is so important in that age and
that people are interested in all sorts
of things that go hand in hand with
being interested in theater people are
interested in disguise and dress up and
they ask questions about gender that
seem really pertinent to me so you know
it's just to me the really really
interesting period of Chinese history
and in gathering up the stories and
assimilating them what are some of the
conclusions you reached in terms of the
human connections and community you
mentioned earlier well I mean when I
started researching the book what I was
hoping for was basically ways that
people at the time conceived of space
you know I was really interested in a
world where people don't actually travel
very much in that period and yet enough
people in a tiny minority do travel that
a lot of people are really interested in
the idea of what lies beyond their
immediate horizons so I thought there
would be all sorts of stuff about
spatial understanding and when I started
trying to impose that on the text I
really wasn't finding anything
particularly interest
down that road and what I realized was
it it's one way to one way to think
about space and the size of the human
community is the the the alternative
title for the book which I only came up
with after the book was published was
fancy meeting you here because that's
another way to think about how many
people there are in the world what are
the you know how many times have you sat
down on the train and you you saw
someone you sat down you go fancy
meeting you here what are the odds right
but that moment is really thematized in
Chinese literature of this period people
meditate on what it means when you run
into someone you know in and it is a way
of thinking about the population of what
it means to be a stranger what it means
to be a family member so you know that
that's the the how how the boat kind of
began okay and tell me what was one of
the most surprising things you found in
doing the research for the book I
shouldn't be surprised by this anymore
but what I found surprising was how
really deep and careful and methodical a
lot of these popular writers were
questions that we usually think of as
being anthropological I've often said
that traditional Chinese philosophy is
sufficiently narrow in its concerns you
know it's basically its ethics that a
lot of interesting intellectual work is
essentially pushed out into other forums
and so Chinese drama and fiction which
traditionally have been read as kind of
you know low forms really aren't you
know it's where a lot of people who
don't have any other way to ask certain
questions end up posing those questions
okay well thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work no thank you for having me for
more information about Professor Liu and
her work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at yeah
you